hello everyone
I think uh I think that sound is on so
welcome thanks for coming
my name is Mark Seaman and if you're
interested in knowing more about me
there's information there unblocked
uploaded DK and I'm on Twitter at play
So if you think that's interesting and
you can follow me there as well
um so so this talk is uh is um is about
software development productivity and
um
I think that we all know or we we
probably have this um understanding that
we're probably not as as productive as
we'd like to be and even if we feel that
we you know ourselves feel very
productive we often have this uh feeling
that our at least our managers uh don't
think that we're as productive as we'd
like to be and I think in general we
have a problem with um with productivity
and software development in the sense
that we could probably do better than we
usually do
um so so this talk is about software
development productivity and I'm not
claiming that I have the one and only
reason and the one and only uh solution
to the problem of software development
productivity that's probably it's
probably a multi-faceted you know
hard problem to solve but what I'm going
to talk about here today is I believe at
at least a major component I think if
you can you know start to address the
problem that I'm going to talk about
here you can probably you know that's my
impression anyway you can really do
something about your productivity but
it's not going to be easy it's going to
be hard
um so I'm not I'm not offering any sort
of quick fixes here the problem that I
think is quite fundamental to a lot of
the things that we um a lot of the
problems that we experience is that we
we waste a lot of time reading existing
code so lots of different people have
had you know opinions on that Robert C
Martin in one of the books he has
published writes the ratio of of time
spent reading versus writing is well
over ten to one and other authors seem
to agree with the general notion their
estimates at the ratio you know might
vary a little bit from you know from
from source to Source but that's you
know the notion is that we spend a lot
of time reading existing code
and you know the fact that we have to
read code at all is probably inescapable
so it's not that I say that's there's
not nothing wrong with reading existing
code it's just that you may spend too
much time reading existing code and
that's going to slow you down and let me
try to explain why that is so we can
take that ratio if we you know just take
that for the sake of argument the 10 to
1 ratio there and we can plot it out and
try to illustrate that with a figure
like this one so the um so the orange
yellow boxes there are you know
represent all the time that we spend
reading existing code and then the green
box there you know represents the time
that we spend writing new code so that's
ten to one
um usually when you hear people talk
about software development productivity
you'll often hear you know productivity
discussed in terms of producing new code
so you will have you know software
vendors who are who want you to have you
know use their new you know development
environment or you will have Library
authors that you know want you to use
their new libraries or Frameworks or
language designers that think their
language is better than the one that
you're using up until now or the new
version is better than the old version
of the language that happens a lot too
so that's often this sort of the framing
of of discussions of of productivity
but if we look at that in isolation we
could imagine just for the sake of
argument that we can actually cut down
the time that we have to spend writing
new code by 50 now that's not realistic
at all but just for the sake of argument
you can say well let's say okay so so a
50 reduction of the time that we have to
spend writing new code that sounds like
a huge productivity Improvement but
really it's not like in the overall
picture it's more like 4.5 percent
now don't get me wrong here I'm I don't
have anything I don't have a problem
with productivity improvements in the in
the writing you know part you know when
when there's a new version of you know
various different editors out I install
the new version as well and I take
advantage of the new features for you
know being a little bit more you know
productive in terms of writing code
because there are other benefits of
having those you know small improvements
they sometimes they make you happier
because you you know you feel more
productive and that's that's a nice
thing as well but you know when you
really get down to it you even though
you might feel more productive if you
can use a new feature in in a
development environment it's probably
not really going to matter much in the
great scheme of things if you don't do
something about the readability part of
it uh you know even you know even a 50
reduction in the time here wouldn't
really amount to much more than 4.5 and
the reality is that that the
productivity you know improvements that
you get from new versions of a language
or new ID features and so on are
probably much more marginal than that so
so if you really want to tackle your
productivity issues if you know imagine
that you have any of those it would be a
good idea to
start thinking about what do we do about
the readability things if we can cut
down on that that's uh that's a that's a
much better opportunity to actually do
something dramatic about our
productivity so at you know attack the
the orange boxes there not the green one
so um
so we want to make code readable
but we we then need to figure out okay
so how do we determine whether or not
code is readable so something like this
for example is that readable or not and
um you know you can have all sorts of
subjective judge you know you know
opinions uh about whether or not this is
readable so if you're a sharp developer
you'll probably recognize this as being
fairly idiomatic c-sharp I haven't done
anything too fancy here if you're not
actually sharp developer if you do Java
or typescript or you know things from
you know that kind of you know the C
language you can probably still you know
understand what's going on here
um but the point is not so much uh to
talk about this particular piece of code
I will talk a lot about that piece of
code and other pieces of code but not
because I actually want to talk about
what it does what I want to talk about
is how we actually read code
um so I think in order to to answer the
question is this readable yes or no or
maybe a little bit of a fussy yes or no
so yes maybe no
um we need we need to be
um we need to have a way to be a little
bit of you know more objective about
this sort of question that we usually
tend to be so often when you have
discussions about readability you will
have a person in one corner of the room
saying I think this is readable and then
you'll have a person on the other corner
of the room says this is absolutely
unreadable I hate it and then the first
person will come back and say well but
it is and the other one will say but
it's not and you have this sort of
kindergarten level kind of discussion
going which doesn't really lead you
anywhere so it's important to be able to
to talk about these things uh in a in a
way that is a little bit um you know
dispassionate if you will so if we can
make it a little bit more objective that
would be good so let's try to understand
what actually happens when we read code
so usually you know researchers have uh
you know so far figured out is that we
engage in a in a process called
cognitive compilation where basically
what we're trying to do when we
presented with a piece of code like this
that we haven't seen before is that we
start to engage in this process where we
are sort of like trying to pass and
interpret the code and almost run a
little emulator in our brain and try to
imagine what's actually going to happen
so if you do that you'll probably see
that you know one of the first things
that happened in this uh you know piece
of source code is that we create an
object called allocation and if you know
C sharp you know list of table or list
of T in general is a collection and it's
it may change stage you can add things
to it you can remove stuff from it you
can reorder it and you can do all sorts
of things with a collection like that
and depending on what you do that might
then impact you know the run you know
the execution of what what happens next
so it's probably important to keep track
of the state of an object like that so
you sort of you know make a little
mental model for you know in your own
brain and saying okay so so I have this
allocation here which is a collection of
tables and that might be important so
I'm going to keep track of the state of
that and say okay what's what do I
believe is contained within this object
what the state what's the state of this
object and then you go on and and you
interpret more of the code so there's
for each Loop there and you you know
that you know if if what you're for
eating over is empty you're just going
to fall all the way through so in that
case nothing's going to happen to that
allocation object on the other hand if
you have at least one thing then you are
going to do something else
um so here we are searching for a
particular table and
um if we if we find it we do something
if we don't find it we do something else
so this little table is Curly brackets
that's a that's a C sharp pun basically
meaning if table is something and that
is supposed to null so basically what it
says there is is if table is not null
we'll do one thing otherwise we'll do
another one so if if table is null we're
just going to fall through again if
table is not null if it's something
we're going to do uh you know something
with that allocation so what do we do
here you'll notice is we remove the
table and then we sort of add another
table back in
um so there's still only one object that
we're keeping track of in our memory
um so um so um so that's probably not
not too hard to follow so again I'm not
talking you through this in order to
talk you through this particular
algorithm I'm talking you through this
in order to to try to outline what
happens in the brain when a programmers
typically you know read code that they
haven't seen before and this you know
the the code in the yellow box there you
can see we remove something from the
collection then we add another thing to
the collection people always get a
little bit confused about that because
they say well table dot Reserve will
change the state of the table it doesn't
it returns a new table that is now
reserved and that's what we add back so
that's why that's a little bit odd but
people always get confused about that so
I just thought that I'd call it out
so basically
um we have a few
um a few ways to talk about the
complexity of this code and we can say
well so the the um the number of objects
that we have to keep track of of state
of is one there's basically only one
object where we really change State and
what happens there is fairly trivial so
it's not too hard so it's only one one
thing that actually changes state that
seems like something that we can do
that's not difficult to understand so
that's probably readable and there are
three different you know alternative
pathways through the system
uh denoted or depicted by those three um
arrows there and this is a measurement
known as cyclomatic complexity which you
may have heard about before but it's
basically just that you know the notion
that we are we're trying to figure out
what are the alternative pathways
through the system so what that tells us
is also that it tells us a little bit
about the cognitive load of reading a
piece of code like this one because we
somehow need to
um keep in our brain the notion that it
might you know this code might behave in
one of three different ways so it's
almost like a little super position of
states where you have three different
you know pathways through the code but
we in order to understand this method we
sort of have to have to understand how
all of those three Pathways work so that
might tax our brain a little bit but I
would say this is readable because the
numbers you know three encyclomatic
complexity and the number you know one
one object that may change state that um
that's probably okay so why do I see say
that that is probably okay okay do you
have some sort of threshold where I say
okay so is three if psychological
complexity of three is is fine you know
what about cyclomatic complexity of five
is that still okay seven is that still
okay ten is that still okay 50 is that
still okay so there must be some sort of
threshold where we say Okay
um you know around that threshold it's
probably going to be difficult to follow
so there's this notion there's a and and
a result from experiments experimental
psychology uh from 1956 by a researcher
called George a Miller an experimental
psychologist who came up with this um he
published this paper you probably heard
the title of it it's called The Magical
number seven plus minus two and
basically what he found back then was
that we in short-term memory we can keep
track of about seven things you know
give and take so
um
so that's that's pretty much all we have
to deal with in our short-term memory
and this result is from 1956 it's
actually quite robust it's been you know
other resources have attempted to
reproduce that requirement later on and
they tend to arrive at you know
basically maybe even an even smaller
threshold uh but but the order of
magnitude is is about right so I'll just
kind of stick with the magical number
seven because seven is a magical number
so let's just assume for the sake of
argument that that's as much stuff we
can keep track of in our short-term
memory you can just keep track of seven
things in short-term memory
so um so George a Miller you know asked
his uh you know um the people who
partook in the experiment he asked them
to keep track of lots of different
things you know remembering random
numbers and so on uh he also sometimes
asked them to remember other things they
were more like clusters of information
so instead of just being you know
primitive things like numbers they might
be clusters of information and he called
those chunks
um so in general we need to realize that
the stuff that we need to keep track of
when we're reading code is is not you
know primitive things like numbers but
more like chunks of information like
objects and how objects you know
interact with each other and um and we
we do have a little bit of a problem
though because you know in in a real
code base
we have a lot of stuff going on so you
might if you start you know an entirely
Greenfield uh code base you might start
with hello world and hello world is
literally just one thing going on
there's not a lot of stuff happening
there but actually you know start to add
more things to the code base you tend to
you know keep on adding things and
adding things and adding things so they
pile up so you know a realistic code
base is not going to have you know at
most seven things going on that you know
that would fit in short-term memory but
what a real code base is probably going
to have is it's going to happen have you
know seven seven thousand things going
on or seven million things going on so
there's going to be a lot of things
going on and um and that's not going to
fit in our short-term memory
so um so we we have a couple of options
here you know
um I'll get back to how we can work with
short-term memory in a little while
because I think it's it's really
beneficial if we can but the other
option that we have is that we can start
to rely more on long-term memory so
long-term memory in the brain is a
completely different thing
um we may not even understand how vast
it is if there's any sort of limit to it
um
various different you know brain
researchers seem to have different
Notions of you know exactly how
long-term memory uh Works some people
say that we actually never forget
anything but it's just that we lose the
ability to locate those memories
I don't know but at least you know
long-term memory is a completely
different uh kind of thing the problem
with long-term memory though is that
um it's slow
so um
it takes time to actually learn things
and I commit them to long-term memory if
you ever done a you know a starting you
know University you know education or
something similar you know that you have
to you know study and repeat the same
things over and over again until they
actually stick so it takes time to make
things stick in in long-term memory
um so this seems to me to be the
strategy that most organizations sort of
default to when we talk about the code
base a couple of years ago I was
visiting a client of mine who wanted me
to help them with um you know improving
their legacy code base and they showed
me some of the code and it was just like
you know all the other Legacy code bases
that I've seen in in terms of being way
too complex and I had the opportunity to
talk to some of the developers who were
working on that code base and one of
them was the most recent hire he did
he'd been there in two two years and so
I thought okay so he can probably still
remember what it was to start in this
code base so I asked him so when you
came when you started this job
two years ago how long would you say
that it took you until you were actually
able to work on your own you know on
your own hand in this code base and he
didn't miss a beat he just said three
months you know that was absolutely
clear to him it took him three months to
actually be able to work in that code
base on his own and I think the reason
for that is that he during those three
months he was working
you know diligently
um to figure out you know how do who how
do I commit the structure of this you
know
um this Legacy code base how do I commit
that structure to long-term memory and
once he sort of had that figured out he
could start to work with the code base
because now he actually understood it so
it's not that we can't work with code
bases if there's more than seven things
going on it's just that we have to rely
on a different memory access strategy
and that you know memory strategy and
I'm talking about human memory here I'm
not talking about computer memory that
memory strategy is quite slow it seems
to be orders of magnitude slower than
you know utilizing short-term memory
now while I've been talking you'll
notice that this little animation here
just keeps on adding more and more
chunks of information and they sort of
start to press against each other and
also form this you know more or less
regular looking grid so another option
of try you know so one option is to rely
on long-term memory and basically try to
keep everything in memory in long-term
memory and then hope the structure of
the code base doesn't change too
radically because then you know that
knowledge would become obsolete so
that's that's one option to say okay we
just have to rely on on long-term memory
and but that's you know the reason why
we often spend a lot of time reading
code because it's hard
now another option that we might have is
to say well okay what if we could you
know pick out at most seven of those
things you know and take them out of the
entire context and look at them in
isolation if we can isolate seven of
those at most seven of those things
enough from the surrounding context
there shouldn't be more going on that we
can actually you know deal with that or
think about that in terms of short-term
memory
so uh so we could you'd imagine that we
that we pick out you know just uh at
most seven of those things and if we do
that we'll arrive at something that
might look a little bit more like this
um so I call this figure a hex flower
because it looks a little bit like a
flower it's made up of hexagons so
that's that's the reason for the name
so this is a you know you can you can
think about this as a symbol of you know
your short-term memory or almost like a
logo of your uh for your short-term
memory in the sense that this depicts
the the capacity of your short-term
memory sort of in context you know you
know imagine implied that it's it exists
in a context with a lot of other stuff
but now we're just isolating seven
things and and if we can if we can do
that if we can isolate at most seven
things and look at those in isolation we
might be able to understand that you
know using our short-term memory instead
of our long-term memory
so if we can do that
it means when we look at some code if we
can organize code in such a way that
this works it means that you know when
whenever we look at a piece of code it's
isolated enough that it makes sense in
isolation and one of the keys to doing
this is abstraction so each of those
seven things that might interact there
might be seven objects that are
interacting uh something like that that
you know each of those objects will
probably be at a level of abstraction
where if you want to know how that
particularly works you can still zoom in
on that and you know that should reveal
a new layer of complexity and in that
new layer of complexity we still want to
respect the the cognitive boundaries you
know the brain the width where that we
are you know equipped with has this
boundary of about seven things or this
threshold of about seven so if we don't
respect that we can't you know rely on
our short-term memory and then we have
to rely on long-term memory instead
so if we keep on zooming in on layers of
abstraction we might say okay so so
here's an example of what that might
look like in code so um
so all the code that I'm showing you
here is from my book the code that fits
in your head I have a couple of copies
sitting down here I'm going to give them
away at the end of the talk
um so stick around for that if you're
interested
um but what we'll be looking at here is
a create method that sits on a class
whose responsibility it is to you know
talk to a SQL Server database and it's
you know whether or not a SQL server is
not really important what we want to
know here is whether this code is
readable in other words does it fit in
your head does it fit in your short-term
memory so if we try to do a little bit
of a
of quantification here we try to say
well what's some objective measurements
of you know how much stuff is going on
we could we could try to you know look
at cyclomatic complexity and we can we
can see that there's only two pathways
through the code because uh you know one
pathway is that reservation is null and
then we throw it and not an argument not
exception there and then nothing else
happens or we just go all the way
through the code and do whatever it is
that the the code says in a linear
fashion so there's only those two
options
so um so if the threshold is seven and
we only have two alternative Pathways
that's probably okay what about counting
you know interacting objects well at the
beginning we just start to enumerate the
objects and say you know how many
objects do we actually have interacting
here so we have a restaurant ID that's
one reservation that's two we have a
connection string which you might wonder
where where that comes from but that's a
read-owned property on the class it's
just a string and if you're not a sharp
developer a property is just a glorified
class field it's a get a method
so a connection string we can use that
to create something called a SQL
connection that's a con there's another
object we use the con the con object and
then together with another string create
reservation SQL so again you can't see
where that comes from but this this is
not even a property this is just a
hard-coded string that's just you know
holds the actual SQL you know the T SQL
you know query that I'm going to execute
against the database it's not a query
when you you have a create I think but
anyways
um it's just a hot coded string uh with
placeholders and then we use that to
create a sixth object
um and that's it you know there are no
further objects involved here because
once we've done creating those objects
we basically just go ahead and modify
some of those objects and you'll notice
that we actually only end up modifying
two of them so we we do modify command
six times and we also modified you know
con towards the end because we open the
connection and that actually changes the
state of the object the rest of the
objects are actually not involved in
state changes as but you might have to
um well let's put it some some in
another way it's fairly obvious that you
know if you have an input argument
that's an integer you know the one
labeled one that's not going to change
State because you know input arguments
that our integers are immutable and it's
not by by reference it's not being
passed by reference so you can't change
it so it seems fairly obvious and these
strings are all read-only as well so
they're not going to change State either
it turns out the reservation is actually
also an immutable object what we call
the value of objects so um so that's not
going to change State either so that's
really only two things that you know end
up Changing State but even if we want to
be a little bit more coarse green and
just you know blindly count all the the
objects that are involved in this
particular little piece of code it's um
there's only six things going on and if
you have a limit on your short-term
memory that where you can keep track of
at least seven things this should be
good so at least according to two two
alternative ways of two of quantifying
things you know cyclomatic complexity
and object activation count this I would
I would claim is readable because it
fits in your head
so what we could do is we can you know
one way to illustrate that is we can
enumerate all the things that are
happening or we can try to assign them
each to that you know hex flower here
and again the I'm not suggesting that
you actually have a little you know
stack of paper with all of those hex
flowers lying besides you and you sort
of actually do this you know type you
know putting them in like that although
I think this might actually be a good
business model for me to sell those
papers but but anyways
um now the point is I'm just trying to
sort of create a visual illustration of
you know what I'm aiming at here so so
the notion is that the general idea is
that we should think about this hex
flower as as again A visual
representation of your short-term memory
now the um
the create method that I just showed you
here was interesting because it was at
the lowest level of abstraction in the
sense that
um it didn't really call any of my other
code you know you have a code base with
a lot of stuff going on and often you
will write code that calls some other
code that you also wrote that caused
some other code that you also wrote
um but that's that's not really what was
happening here the most of the code that
we were just looking at let's see if we
can go back
um yeah my animation sort of only go one
way we can't go back oh let's go back
there's what there's always there's
always a way to go back let's let's have
a look at it again
all right so so the point that I was
trying to make here is that most of the
code that we're interacting with here is
uh is is framework code it's not
something that we wrote so this is sort
of like the lowest level of abstraction
in terms of user code uh because SQL
connection and SQL command is not a
class that I have written that's just
part of the.net framework
okay so that's okay let's see if we can
go move forward again here so that's
that's just the point that I was trying
to make but you might then say all right
so but that create method that we just
looked at here
um you know some of our code is going to
call that and if that you know if we
already have six things going on inside
of the create method in terms of object
activation then if we have some other
code that calls that and it probably
does some other things as well doesn't
it mean that well maybe we can you know
keep things at seven things or fewer at
the lowest level of abstraction but what
about higher levels of Attraction isn't
that gonna compound you know add up so
that the rest of the code is not going
to fit in our head what do we do about
that so so the point is that the our
short-term memory is as it is and we
can't really do anything about that so
we should be able to you know not only
zoom in but we should also be able to
zoom out and say at a higher level the
code should be organized in such a way
that it respects the cognitive
constraints of our you know short-term
memory because if that's not true
it's not going to fit in our short-term
memory and then again we have to rely on
long-term memory and that means we're
going to spend a lot of time reading or
trying to understand the code
so if we Zoom all the way out we should
actually be able to end up at the entry
point of the application and say does
that fit in my head you know at a high
level of abstraction does that fit in my
head and uh and this is uh this this is
the entry point of the application I
didn't write it it's just a there's a
wizard that you know if you start a new
asp.net project you just go through and
that's what it does and if you've ever
seen any of these before you know that
all the all the interesting things
happen in the class called startup now
I'm not assuming that you know asp.net
it's not the point here but I'm just
trying to say well even at the highest
level of abstraction does it fit in my
head and you can see there's not a lot
of stuff going on here there's no
cyclomatic complexity to speak of and
there's only really three things going
on all the all the interesting stuff
happens here in startup
so um so if I want to learn about you
know what what's the structure of
startup what does startup look like I
should be able to go and and you know
change my perspective you know change
the scope of analysis uh if you will and
go just look at startup and when I do
that you know web Builder and arcs
should no longer be relevant for my
understanding so let's try to do that
and we can just zoom in a little bit and
say okay if we look at startup do we
need to understand web Builder and arcs
in order to understand the structure of
this class and I would I would claim
that's not really the case these things
are now or out of scope if you will in
terms of our understanding we don't need
to understand how those work
so again if we try to quantify here do
we have a lot of stuff going on no we
don't really you know uh again if you
have done any asp.net development you
know that all the interesting things
happen inside those two methods
configure and configure services and
then we have this um Constructor here
that you know that that populates the
the uh the property there so they sort
of go together so there's only like
three things going on there so again
that you know at that level of
abstraction the code fits in your head
and more so even easily
so what happens inside of configure
services this is probably the one that
you want to to look at is that organized
in such a way that it fits your
short-term memory let's go ahead and
have a look at that one so you'll notice
that well um you know the the you'd
probably not be surprised to learn that
this is also organized so that it fits
in your head but you'll notice that it
doesn't fit on the screen at least not
it doesn't fit on a on a PowerPoint
slide so there's a little bit more going
on you know towards the uh you know
below the screen there but we're going
to scroll up here that's not it's not
very interesting actually there's no
surprises there
um but again instead of just having this
subjective discussion on whether or not
this is readable let's try to ask
ourselves does it fit in short-term
memory and we can try a couple of
different quantification mechanisms to
answer that question so we can say
what's the cyclomatic complexity do we
have any alternative pathways through
this code and it turns out that we don't
it's just it just runs straight through
so cyclomatic complexity is one because
there's only one pathway through the
code so that's as low as it gets so on
that measurement it's it's um it
couldn't be simpler
what about object activation we can try
to count all the objects that are
involved most of those objects here are
actually not you know immutable integers
or string they're actually objects that
may change state so this one may tax our
brain a little bit more than the create
method that I showed you before but
still
there's only six things going on and you
might say but you know below the screen
there might be more but they're not it
turns out that they're they're not so um
so again we could say well 6 is less
than seven so according to that
quantification mechanism we should feel
fairly confident that this code is
readable the point that I'm trying to
make in terms of you know fitting code
into your short-term memory is that
we if you can work mostly with your
short-term memory you should be able to
encounter codes you've never seen before
and spend only a couple of minutes so
you don't have to spend hours in order
to understand what's going on and maybe
you can't do it just you know while I'm
talking here but if you sit with this
just by yourself you should be able to
understand the structure of this code in
in a matter of a couple of minutes and
I'm not talking about all the details
that happen behind the scenes so if we
scroll down for example you can see
there's a sort of a list of things that
happen in a lot of you know um hilber
methods that are being called that do
you know some more details set up and
I've often encountered programmers who
feel that they don't understand uh you
know things until they've understood all
the details
so if you're in that camp you might say
yeah but I don't know what happens
inside of configure authorization so
that means as long as I don't understand
what happens inside of that
I don't understand this code at this
level of abstraction and I you know
basically what I'm trying to say here is
let go of that notion let you know you
know details matter and if you need to
know something about you know
authorization you go and look at that
code but to understand this the overall
structure of the code that we're looking
at right now
that should be understandable you should
be under you should be able to
understand how the code that we're
looking at here sort of in plays
together with each other and then you
can say there is again the the level of
abstraction is super high here so we are
almost at the entry point of the
application so we are not learning any
details about how the application works
this is more like you know this gives us
a little bit of a preview of what's the
architecture what's the structure of
this particular code base and then you
can say okay if I want to know about
authorization is it you know is there
authorization is it username password is
it JWT you know how does how does that
work I can go and look at configure
authorization or you know as most people
probably want to do they want to say I I
want to need and I need to know how the
the data store works and you can you
know configure repository looks like a
promising name and then you can go in
and have a look at that and the point is
when you do that and when you go and
look at configure repository you know
that code should also be structured in
such a way that everything that is in
scope there is all you need to know and
what actually happened at this level of
abstraction should now be out of scope
because when you zoom in on the detail
the surrounding context should now
become irrelevant
so um so that's another way to sort of
enumerate things this is a little bit of
a cheat enumeration here but basically
the point that I'm trying to make still
is that we should be able to
um to work at various different levels
of abstraction very high level of
self-estraction where there's not a lot
of detail but you get you know a high
level view of of how things work and how
things play together and then you can
zoom into very low levels of details and
you then you can see how those actually
work but when understanding when trying
to understand the low level details you
don't have to understand the high level
structure of things
all right so
um so one thing that I sort of left
dangling there is that I said well so
the create method that we started
looking at is some of my code or some of
the code in this code base is going to
call that and
we might be worried that the the um the
complexity inside of a method like like
create method even though it's it's well
and good enough within the short-term
memory ourselves but then when we try to
combine it with other code that does
other things but that may have a little
bit of complexity itself don't those
things add up and then become difficult
to understand and that's what happens in
you know in a normally structured code
base where people haven't thought about
this thing
um but you can absolutely write code in
such a way that that doesn't happen
um so um so here's an example of that so
in general I'd say what what is the key
to avoiding those kinds of details to
leak out into the next level of
abstraction and the overall answer to
that is encapsulation that is the actual
purpose of encapsulation you know object
oriented encapsulation most people think
that encapsulation means information
hiding which I think is a is a bit of a
misunderstanding
encapsulation means that you have a
sufficient level of abstraction so that
you can think about an object
um you know ask just one thing instead
of all you know instead of thinking
about all the implementation details
inside the object you can think about an
object as being one thing
um so um so I'm very much in the camp of
you know viewing encapsulations as they
described by Bert van Meyer so if you're
interested in that uh you can
well you could go and read object
oriented software construction uh or um
or or other things so there's plenty of
literature about that
um but I would I would claim that
there's a little bit of a shortcut to to
encapsulation where instead of just
relying on uh a fussy notion of of you
know contracts and pre and post
conditions and invariants and so on
um if you can there's a shortcut to to
have things that have good encapsulation
that's actually you know more concrete
easier to measure easier to be objective
about and that's what I'm going to talk
about now so I think
um if we if we just come back to this
allocate method here so we just
established that it has a cyclomatic
complexity of three and if we just be I
want to be core screened and count all
the objects that are involved here
there's actually six objects although we
did establish before that only one of
them really really changed state
uh but if we want to be a little bit
unsophisticated in our analysis here we
can say well there's six things going on
we can't have those six things
um you know escaping to the next level
of abstraction if if I'm sitting at the
next level of abstraction I'm the I'm
writing the code that calls this
allocate method if I have to understand
the implementation details of what's
going on inside of allocate I need to
understand those six things then the
calling code is not going to fit in my
head because then I need to add those
six things to some other things that I'm
doing out there in the calling code so
it's very important that these six
things that that are happening inside of
the allocate method that they don't
escape they have to be staying within
this scope that's encapsulation we can't
allow that complexity to to escape so
that you have to understand that on the
next level and I would claim that this
is true of the allocate method as it's
written here and there's two reasons for
that now first of all this method has no
side effects
so what does a side effect mean so a
side effect is basically something that
changes the observable state of the
program either you know directly or
transitively so what do I mean by
changing the state of the system well if
you send an email you can observe that
if you um if you delete a row in a
database you can probably observe that
because you know something else you know
changes when you start to query or look
at the database and the state of the
database if you write to disk you change
the state of the system if you change
pixels on the screen you do something
that has an observable side effect so
there are lots of things where you have
side effects and side of side effects
basically the reasons why we are writing
software but if you can avoid that
that that means that the code that you
are looking at is a little bit easier to
understand so do I have any of these
things in the allocate method do I send
email here no it doesn't look like that
am I writing to disk no it doesn't look
like that I'm acquiring a web service
now not not really am I you know
printing you know changing pixels on the
screen no not really okay so I have I
have no side effects here
um so there's another
property of the code that we're looking
at here and that is it always returns
the same you know output value for the
same input so again we can we can look
at that and we can say okay so um so
what would be ways where that is not
true you know if um if I'm doing some
sort of random number generation and I'm
relying on a random number in order to
you know go one way or another that
would mean that you know even if the
input the reservations the reservation
says input and the the tables property
is also part of the input no that you
know that would that might you know if I
did any sort of random number generation
I relied on a random number in order to
do one on another thing that might
change the output but that's not
happening here I'm also not relying on
you know the current date and time so
I'm not looking at you know is this a
Sunday and then I'm doing something
special if it's a Sunday that's not the
case here as well
um I'm not calling any sort of you know
out of process web service or anything
else like that so there's nothing uh you
know external that can change the output
if the input is the same the output is
always going to be the same
so those two properties uh qualities you
know combined uh produces this thing we
call it pure function so the allocate
method is the pure function and pure
functions are interesting because
they're referentially transparent and I
know that I'm using some some fancy
words here but basically referential
transparency means that the function
call is equal to its result so if you
already know what the result is there's
no reason to call the function because
the only thing the function does is that
it produces the result
um so um so those two things are are
equal to each other now this is
different from a normal you know
procedure where if you have a procedure
that has a side effect you know you
might have something going on in your
way write a little method that Returns
the number 42 but before it does that it
you know it writes something else to
disk and that means you can't just
replace the method call with the output
the number 42 because you also care
about this side effect happening now
this is not the case for referentially
transparent functions if you already
have the result the the how you arrived
at the result is actually irrelevant so
this means you can take you know
something you know an algorithm of
arbitrary complexity uh it doesn't
really matter how complex it is
you know towards the end it produces a
result and then the result is all you
need to know about this is what happens
for example when you're using uh
cryptography uh algorithms so typically
if you want to do something with the
cryptography unless that's actually a
specialty you're probably relying on
some sort of on object or an API that
does that for you and then you know you
say okay please take this array of bytes
and encrypt it and then you get another
array of bytes back and then
you're good and you don't care how you
actually arrived at that you know
encrypted array of bytes you just know
that you did so this is this would be an
example of doing that I know
cryptography sometimes involves a little
bit of Randomness but you can you can
factor that out so that you can you know
feed in a deterministic random number
generator if if you wanted to do that
so the reason why I think it's
interesting that a function is equal to
its result is that it means when we look
at allocate from the outside
if we know that this is a pure function
which it is it means it's how it arrives
at that allocation that it returns is
not really relevant for the caller the
only thing that the caller needs to
understand is that allocate is an
allocation okay because you can notice
on the last line of code it returns an
allocation so we can think about this
even though it has some you know
complexity as being just one thing and
the point is that all the complexity
that's inside of this function here does
not escape the only thing that escapes
is one thing the allocation that it
returns so this means it fits in your
head it you know when we look at it from
the next level of abstraction it is just
one thing we can truly put it in just
one cell in that Higgs flower and that's
okay because all the complexity stays
within the the pure function it doesn't
leak through
right so um so to summarize we should be
able to look at things at various
different levels we should be able to go
and zoom in at another level of
abstraction and then if we want to make
the code readable we should make sure
that it's it's structured in such a way
that it is you know that it respects the
human uh limitations of the short-term
memory which is about you know seven
things so we should be able to do that
you know if we zoom in on the you know a
lower level of detail and we should be
able to do that if we zoom out and look
at the highest level of detail which
might be the entry point and in all of
those cases we should keep on you know
structuring the code in such a way that
there's at most seven things going on
because that's what the brain wants us
to do
so um so here's that animation once more
just because it looks good
um so um so we do understand that if we
just pick some arbitrary level of
abstraction and we look at some code and
we say it's structured in that way you
know when we look at it at that level of
abstraction that's fine it's
understandable we also still know that
even if we don't you know at this level
of abstraction we are not caring about
the details we know that the details are
there so within each of those you know
seven you know hexagons here if we've
structure the code the same all the way
through there's going to be you know in
each of those hexagons there's going to
be you know at most seven other hexagons
for a total of 49 hexagons here now 49
does not fit in your brain that's not
the point is exactly that
um even though we acknowledge that this
is the case we're not thinking about
more than one level of abstraction at a
time because it gets even worse because
each of those 49 hexagons if we keep on
doing this will have you know maybe
seven others that will have you know
seven others and so on
so um so this this figure I called the
fractal hex flower because this is a
fraxel figure
so if you're not convinced that this is
a fractal you say Ah that's not a fact
so you're expecting something like the
mandelbroad set something like that I'll
show you another fraxel which is
definitely a fractal this is known as
the [__] snowflake where we just you
know start subdividing straight lines
into you know putting a little triangle
on it if um if you notice what happened
there and and this is a well-known you
know fractal in that you know discipline
of mathematics that you know deals with
those things and you can keep on zooming
in on the uh on the edge of the [__]
Snowflake and we can just keep on
rendering
um you know smaller and smaller details
if we want to we have to stop rendering
in terms of you know screen granularity
here but we if we imagine that we zoom
in we can keep on zooming in forever and
that's the same thing we can do with
this one we can keep on adding new uh
levels of abstraction into this figure
if we wanted to I just stopped at four
iterations because if I add a fifth
layer here just becomes one green thing
it basically just looks like a green
blob
all right so um
so the point is that you know we I think
we can cut down on the on the um on the
reading time of the existing code if we
structure the code in such a way that it
fits in our heads so and that's also the
title of the book I am I am actually
done with the talk here now but I also
left a little room for um you know doing
a little bit of a q a if you will so so
I was planning on on giving away the two
copies of the book that I have sitting
down here if no one stole them yeah no
they're still there
um so um so the first two people who are
you know fortunate enough to um to ask a
decent question uh will get the copies
uh but I'll be happy to answer more
questions than two and I'm afraid that
because of the um of the lights up there
I'm really having trouble seeing if
you're raising your hands up there maybe
can we turn the lights down a little bit
if there's any anyone here who's
actually listening
the in the AV Department over there
hello
is it possible to Turn Down the Lights a
little bit because I want to see the
audience now
that's a little bit
yeah that that gets better I should have
brought my sunglasses right all right if
you're sitting just below the the lights
there you're basically out of luck I'm
afraid
um all right but uh let's see does
anyone have any questions
I don't just want to go with the people
in the front row but um yeah there's one
of up there that I can see yes sir
when you consider cyclomatic complexity
does that count as a thing
all right so let's see if I understand
what you what you are asking about you
say when I'm when I'm counting things
that are going on one of the things one
of the measurements that I use is
cyclomatic complexity but I also counted
objects and are you asking whether I
want you know if I have six objects and
a cyclomatic complexity of two are you
asking or whether I want to add those
two things together it
yes that's that's the okay so you you
basically you know by asking a question
you you figure out that you actually
already understood the answer I think
that's a that's actually something that
I write about in the book as well is
that sometimes just asking a question
might lead to Insight so I think that
still leads to the Insight that you
might want to have can you pass it up
please
um
if if that's possible that's thanks
you're so friendly thanks thanks a lot
um yeah but so basically it's just to
reiterate
um the um the cyclomatic complexity is
one measure uh the object activation is
another measure one thing that I didn't
talk about which I actually actually
think is a really easy measure to look
out for is just lines of code so those
are just three into P you know in
individually independent kinds of
measurements where each of them are
probably it's probably a good idea to
keep keep all three in mind but I'm not
adding them together they're just what I
really want to do with these kinds of
measurements is to enable you to have a
discussion about readability that is a
little bit more objective
um than just the kindergarten argument
where you know one person says I don't
like it and the other person says but I
like it and then you go yes no yes no
yes no so if you can start having the
discussion where you say yeah but the
cyclomatic complexity is this or the
object your activation count is this so
we have this you know many number of
lines of code then you can perhaps
hopefully have a little bit of a more
dispassionate discussion about the code
quality in in the code that you are
working with together that's that's more
the point that's that's the um I'm
basing this talk on this is just not
something that I pulled out of thin air
it's actually based on on practices that
I just arrived at over you know maybe 10
or 15 years where you know I keep on
running into this having the same
discussions with people where you know
developers will ask me yeah but the mark
why do you think it's time to refactor
this particular code right now and and
then you know slowly I've arrived at
this um these Notions well where I say
well I actually think that this is
getting too complex because of you know
cyclomatic complexity or because of
object activation and that seems to
generally be something that most people
can accept because it's not just my
opinion it's actually something that's
that's just you know disconnected from
subjectivity to a certain degree
I hope that I hope that was more than
you know an answer to the question so
let's see do we have someone over here
or uh
yes we have it I'm sorry uh but we have
someone here as well
uh-huh
no it means that we just need to
actually commit to London memory when we
need to remember what's happening on the
side all right so let's let me see if I
understand the question here so you're
saying well when we are when we're when
we're starting to go deep into the code
and trying to start to look at the
details then what happens to all the
other things that are sitting maybe at
the same level are abstraction but but
not the detail that we're looking at
right now that's that's your question so
so you basically ask and then you said
do we then have to rely on long-term
memories in order to understand you know
all the other things that might happen
uh while um while we're looking at a
piece of of detail code that's your
question right did I get that right okay
good
um so the point that I'm trying to make
here is that I and I said this in a side
remark I said well a lot of code is
organized in such a way that that's
actually what you need to do exactly
what you said here but what I want you
to start thinking about is to say even
if you're at a very detailed level there
might be a lot of other code you know at
the same level of detail but when you're
looking at one piece of code that has a
certain level of detail you should be
able to understand that in isolation of
everything else so all the other things
that are actually sitting out there
should be irrelevant you know this
little piece of code should be self you
know contained enough that you can
understand it on its own terms
um and I understand that a lot of code
is not written like that but that's
where what I'm aiming for so there's a
couple of ways uh where you can that
will help having that sort of design so
first of all I talked about functional I
talked about pure functions so
functional programming is one way where
you can say so a pure function is
something that only acts on its input
and that means if you if you um if you
don't give a pure function more input
that you know the entire code still fits
in your head
then it's going to be completely
isolated in
from everything else that happens in the
code base so that's that's one practical
approach to it if you find FP practical
which some people don't
um another another practical approach to
to trying to get to that sort of design
is test driven development because if
you can have a a thing that you can
exercise from a unit test in isolation
from its dependencies then you actually
have you know you should hopefully have
something that is also understandable in
isolation from everything else so that's
another you know way you can attempt to
arrive at a design like this so
wonderful question thanks a lot let's
see if we can get a book up to here and
I'm I'm sorry that I'm out of books but
that doesn't mean that I don't want to
answer any more questions but um can you
can you pass it up here I think that's
going to be a little bit easier this
time around all right so I'm sorry that
you didn't get a book so but I'll be
happy to take your question
layers
follow your principles
can also make it difficult track
from where you're going so it's also
raising it to a higher level how you
structure your projects
architecture and probably have different
reading the code based on how high
levels
yeah let me see if I can re rephrase
your questions so that first of all in
order to see if I understood it and also
so everyone else can can you know
understand what's what's being asked
here so you say if you're having a big
code base with a lot of complexity
you're probably going to have many
layers of abstraction and your concern
is if I understand you correctly is that
that could you know even if we do it in
the way that I'm proposing here where
everything is a small self-contained
thing and the you know the next level up
as an orchestrator that orchestrates on
some other things but that orchestration
is self-contained and so on
um does that make the code difficult to
um does it does it make it difficult to
understand the entire structure of the
code how do we how do we navigate a code
base like that is is that a proper
sort of
your
oh so what's the next step so yeah so so
um so this this um
this way of organizing code is um so the
idea behind fractional architecture is
more to say respect the uh respect the
cognitive constraints of short-term
memory but that does not as address
other questions like questions about
architecture uh is that a better way to
phrase it do I do I have any opinion on
should we organize the code in you know
according to one kind of architecture
another one is that is that a better way
of representing your question
high level code would be more like
describing the business process
and then the
low level
yeah right okay
yeah so so the point being made here is
that maybe we have different kinds of
levels of code so where the high level
code like is like business processes
then we then decompose into business you
know particular business rules and then
maybe we decompose those into how do we
actually achieve those you know what
what are the um what what's the in
what's the i o that's going to be
resolved from that and so on so so
um if that's not a good paraphrase of
your question then uh you know just hang
around and we'll discuss it more you
know once the talk is over
um but um but I think you know that is
that's definitely one way to structure a
code base now this idea of of you know
being being mindful of the limitations
of the human brain and the way that we
read and understand things
um it's not really a um it doesn't
really mean that you can't combine this
idea with other things you know other
kinds of architectures so you can
definitely say
um you know if you want to have a
specific kinds of architecture you can
you know this is this is like a low
level organizing principle but if you
want to have another organizing
principle on top of that that's
definitely possible so the code base for
the book is written um I'm I'm very fond
of this kind of architecture called the
ports and adapters architecture some
people know it as the hexagonal
architecture some people know it as the
onion architecture or the clean
architecture but it's basically the same
idea so that's one way you can organize
you know a code base like that even and
also keeping keeping this notion of you
know readability in mind but there are
other ways you know other other kinds of
application will require other kinds of
architecture and you can you can still
do this uh this you can follow this
notion so I have like three minutes left
so if you have a short question I'll be
happy to take that on the other hand no
yeah okay so there's one one and that's
the last one then
right yeah great
one wonderful question so the question
is when I'm when I'm trying to do what
I've described here then how do I handle
Global shared state
and uh and basically we say well Global
theater is evil we also know those AS
Global variables right
um
so you know occasionally something like
Global share State might be unavoidable
but um but you know again if we're
thinking about that that's something we
need to know about if if we need to know
about a piece of global share state that
is you know one one Global variable is
basically one thing that we always need
to keep in mind so if you have seven of
those you've used up your budget right
um so so basically what I'm saying here
is that if you have all no Ops you're
allowed to have seven Global variables
uh but if you actually want to do
something that's going to you know
subtract from your budget of global
variables so don't don't have Global
variables don't have Global share State
um and I understand you know a database
is global shared state so in the sense
you know most applications will probably
have Global share stage but there's a
way to think about interactions with
something like databases and other
pieces of global shares State uh where
you can factor that out so that it
doesn't really look like you know the
the state does not affect the um
the actual understanding of the code so
you can imagine that you have a global
variable
and if you're looking at the code you
are never you know using that Global
variable so even though it's it's you
know technically there it does not tax
your short-term memory because it's not
involved so that's why I call it object
activation there might be objects that
are on scope you know technically in
scope you could call them if you wanted
to but if you don't they're not taxing
your short-term memory in terms of
understanding and that means they don't
count so I hope that answers your
question and I think by that I'm also
out of time so thanks a lot for coming
and if you want to hang around you know
I'll stick around and answer you know
more questions if if that's interesting
but otherwise you know scoot off to the
next presentation and have fun
[Applause]